الفنان جورج خباز هو مؤلفها مخرج وممثل
ومؤلف اغاني وملحن لبناني وعمل للسنوات
على خشبه المسرح نجحها خلالها في استقطاب
جمهور عريض من مختلف الاعمار والفئات
الاجتماعيه تالق عبر مسرحه الخاصه الذي
طبع هويته الفنيه من خلال مجموعه كبيره من
الاعمال واعاده تقديم مسرحيات لزياده
الرحباني حصاد جورج خباز شهره واسعه في
التلفزيون عبر سلسله من الاعمال الناجحه
وشارك في عدد من الافلام فاز بعضها بجوائز
عالميه كان اخر
افلامها كبيره عند عرضه على منصه نتفليكس
[موسيقى]
الرصاصه الصامته
بطوله يوسف تامر
[موسيقى]
مسلسل مبني على الكوميديا السوداء
امل عرفه النجم الرائعه هو المسلسل هيا
رحله بحث بحث عن الطموح عن الحلم بحث عن
براند لتحقيق حلم هذا المخرج
اولى اعمله اذا بدك ولكن بنفس نكتشف مع
الوقت ان هي رحله بحث عن الذات
بهالرحله بيصير في كثير همم
مشاعر تجاه في المحطه بس اتجاه الاخر
فمسلسل في كل انواع الدراما بيونت وحده
يعني في همم الدراما في القامه كوميديا في
الميوزك الفيل
الفانتازيا في
الرومانس يعني كل انواع اللي بنشوفها
بدراما موجوده بيونت وحده بيتنقل بطريقه
سلسه من خلال شخصيه يوسف هو المخرج الباحث
عن البراندو شرق لحتى نكتشف عوالم هذه
الشخصيه وكواليس الاعمال الفنيه خاصه انه
بدور احداثه باخر بيانات اول تسعينات ففي
كمان بنحاس الشكل في بوك حلو كثير وهون
تحيه كثير كبيره للمخرج امين دورها
المسلسل او ترجمه برؤيه اخراجيه رائعه
جورج يجمع بين الطموح وعدم الاستسلام
ومحبته لوالده بنفس الوقت انزعاجه منه في
المسلسل يعني هذه الشخصيه المركبه يا جورج
هل تمثل جورج وسلام الزوج بعيدا عن
التمثيل
انه انا رميت ببديموقراطي واهلي تركوني
اعمل بالدقيقه ولكن شغله الفنان انه
يقتباس
جدليات وصراعات بالمجتمع ويحولها لمشهديه
انا بشوف كثير من تلاميذي كون معلم
بالجامعه وبعلم الفنون شوف كثير
لحتى يفوتوا بهذا المجال
واهلهم كانوا يحطوا لهم مثل ما بيقولوا
عصري الدولي خوفا عليا لانه مجال الفن
ممكن يكون صعب خبز وكل هذه المقولات
فكانوا هذا الشباب والصبايا همم لدرجه
للفن فانا اذا بدك نقلت اصواتهم بشكل او
باخر بس انا سعيد شخصي لا كنت محظوظ جدا
انه
تركوا لي هامش حريه كبيره اني اختار اعمل
بدي اياه بحياتي
[موسيقى]